I'm growing I can feel growing
um if I can just share about my service
dog real quick please yeah please
um
so I met munin
2011 uh this company called Fallen they
were they were at the SHOT show in Vegas
and my friends went up to them uh kind
of fast forward and like hey Cody's in
the last state I was doing that
investigation
um
and they're like we need to get Cody a
dog and uh
went down to Jackson Wyoming did some
training with other dogs and they're
like this is the dog for you I'm like no
she's a girl I don't need her I want a
manly dog I want like something
terrifying and yeah I trained with all
of them and they were just not good for
me they were just two in the red I need
them like not that
and so they brought back munen she's a
German Shepherd Belgian Mal
she like runs and jumps on this like
platform and like puts her head on my
lap then
um 24 hours later I go home with her and
that dog
same like physically saved my life like
numerous times and
um about January
she was uh I brought the dog ever with
me at work she went to Dives with me I
took her to Free Fall school she [__] on
the mat like it was a big deal uh but
like because she was trapped and she got
trapped in the slide and she was able to
go outside
but I I was so grateful because people
like brought her with me or people out
here made to bring her with me and um
January her uh her hip dysplasia really
kicked in she started going blind and
really seeing all just barking all night
and
I felt I looked at her and I just felt
so bad how I'm I was a bad dog dog
leader and I didn't take her out on
walks every day and I just all this
regret my life and
I didn't think I was strong enough to
like to help her take care of her
it off since January I'm like I can't do
this I'm not strong enough for this
she'll be okay she'll be okay
um
and um she just wasn't then she's in
[__] pain and my dog's she was a
[__] War she's Savage and um
that's the type of dog that just wanted
you to know that she loves so here I am
looking for love for my dad looking for
acknowledgment from other people
and I had it the whole time
and I told myself like I have to I have
to do this like a big this is a big like
step for me and
you're letting go of my service dog was
the hardest thing that I've done a dog
literally saved my life so many times
and uh
but it's also the biggest
growth spurt in my life am I in my in my
recent life that I can really look back
on like I knew this is part of it
because I had to be a leader for her you
know I was I was so selfish
and I felt even worse that I was she was
suffering and I'm like oh she can still
kind of get around she's not that bad
and
but what that dog did to my life
I mean
was is like legendary
and um
but to take her to the vet to schedule
that appointment and to take her there
and to you know [__] bathe there and
groomed her her last day and
it was a it was a part of the process
and another reality that nothing lasts
forever in this life and
I don't know I just I just wanted to
share that I really felt that
letting go of her
Help Me Grow
um because holding on to her pain and
suffering I was holding on to a lot of
my insecurities and
my uh my remorses and my regrets in life
and
I've flashed back my whole life with her
and like things I was doing things I was
going through
and then just to see those eyes and hmm
um
just what a gift you know all these all
these things that we have in life that
are that are there for us to guide us
and it's right [__] there
um
to me that was like the most special
gift I've ever
got the experience with her was her life
and
what having to
I'm gonna say man up but having to like
step up and like
do the thing that I didn't want to do be
a [__] leader
um
it was it put me in this like different
state of uh state of being that I
haven't had in a long time you know so
like
I'm just like [__] it you gotta just get
you gotta keep on [__] going dude
like
this is part of the journey you know
um because when I got muted I wasn't
worried about oh she's gonna die one day
yeah
no one thinks about that no and then
reality comes
um but I'd be doing a hard disservice if
I threw it all away if I didn't take all
the good that she's given me yeah so um
I just wanted to give her a shout out
man yeah man God bless and do you want
to honor her do you want to tell me uh
do you wanna just tell me is there like
one special story about her you said she
saved your life so many times or
anything just by by like honoring her
like something tell me about how special
she was
yeah when I first got her home she
didn't she literally laid on my chest
panting for like weeks at a time
um and I I called them I I call the
people that got her from and they're
really spiritual people and they're like
oh yeah she's taking your demons from
you she's taking your pain from you and
um I feel like she she was just supposed
to be there and the one of the greatest
lessons she taught me that she did for
me was like I judged the [__] out of her
because I'm like I thought I in a state
of like help and desperate desperation I
thought I knew what was best for me
but the the owners of the company they
knew exactly what dog I needed I'm like
I know better
and I'm like how many [__] times I do
that in my life okay all these other
things yeah and then when you just let
go
and you let go your [__] ego you let
go all the stuff and you're like dude
she walks with me the best
she loves me for no other reason that
she loves me
it was just lesson after lesson after
let them she couldn't play fetch for
[__] she was an [__] she would go get
the ball and she would drop it like four
feet in front of you yeah dude I'm like
you [__] dick
um
but man just think about all those
opportunities to
that I would never have had if it wasn't
for her and her helped me heal and
honest and change stigmas even like the
the mental health game in my
organization like why is that guy I have
a dog like [__] you that's why [__]
[__] you man my life is important and
people were like yeah [__] yeah okay and
so the people who got the head on they
got it they understood it the people who
didn't get their head on [__] them yeah
you know and I'm just like
that's how badass my dog is dude I just
get to share time with her and I just
you talked about it earlier and I just I
just wanted to
give my love my my Raven uh [__]
shout out man [__] yeah man I'm glad I'm
really glad you did man I'm really glad
I'm gonna carry that
foreign
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and again grateful that you guys tune in
we've decided we want to take things
just a step further it's a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become part of this community
look I already bore Bam Bam if you want
to become a part of this community
you're going to be able to hear episodes
early and all that ad free and all that
good stuff but there's all this behind
the scenes footage all this stuff that
we've shot that really brings you into
the folks that we've had on the show
really brings you into their world live
chats with me and the folks that I bring
on the show to talk about their world
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll